China is fuming right now because the EU
just banned Tick-Tock from all
government devices see after the U.S and
Canada the European Union followed suit
no more tick tock on staff phones the
reason it's a threat to our national
security and China is fuming the CCP
said that countries Banning Tick-Tock
lack self-confidence in that the
European Union should stop abusing the
concept of National Security but it may
get even worse the U.S and the EU are
thinking about completely Banning
Tick-Tock outright and if that happens
Tick Tock would lose over 260 million
users in more than 13 billion in yearly
Revenue in the CCP they would lose their
most powerful psychological weapon over
the West which is why